they were all minions the certified
country with Sophie chelation
[Music]
welcome back to another edition of
certified country today we're going to
have a little fun with Old Dominion and
I have an exclusive announcement for you
guys about an exciting new album
released I am so pumped about it but
first I want to introduce you to
critical darling and hewlett swift
approves newcomers Evan Dawson you've
got my number you can jump on me
[Music]
you have so many connections to these
awesome people and I want to ask you
about a few of them occur first of all
Taylor Swift goddess that would say I
met a good friend of mine Larissa
Wendorf like one of the first days of
college I felt like niversity natural
and we ended up doing a mash-up of blank
space and style she ended up like
tweeting it out and facebooking it and
saying that she was obsessed with it and
honestly like that definitely
kick-started all of our careers you are
touring with Tim McGraw and Faith Hill
tell me about getting that call getting
asked to go on the road with them it's
just insane because I obviously grew up
listening to both of them and I my
manager is very nonchalant about his way
of breaking news to me and I think it
was just an effective like hey yeah
thinking think about maybe you will send
up for Tim and faith and I was like yeah
let me check my schedule
I think we could make that work yeah and
you know for them to believe in a new
artist is awesome you have also toured
with Merrin Maura I have that was
amazing she asked us to come out before
I even had music I think we sent her a
couple unreleased tracks through some
mutual connections and she just believed
in it which is you know again as a new
artist having somebody believe in you so
early and give you a shot is amazing
it's like this kind of pay it forward
kind of energy last one
tell me about who your biggest musical
influences are I always save three jobs
so I grew up in Orangeville and right
next to where I grew up was Folsom
Prison and so Johnny Cash is a huge
influence on me I love John Fogerty I
love their soul roots the rock kind of
you know country sound that they have
and lastly I'm a huge John Mayer fan I
love his ability to just do it all
himself he does lyrics and sings and
plays guitar is performer and hopefully
I can have half of the success that he
has the dog knows dance
down the road bad dog so what is your
biggest goal for the next year man I I
just want to impact lives like I
hopefully you know when the record comes
out it will be able to reach everybody
and I just I just want to have music out
like I know myself I'm this close but
letting people in on Who I am and what I
believe in is something I'm really
excited for all right all the minions
sophomore album happy end and get out
August 25th and to celebrate they hit up
the I Heart Radio Theater in Los Angeles
for CT was backstage wonder if Jack and
I never made after the Trump and the
guitar something was the best they could
do good enough or there's a hard land to
swallow Alma the name of the album
actually came from a trip we're on a
boat Key West we were playing the new
album so we were talking about one of
the songs on the homages called so you
go and somebody mentioned that it had a
happy ending
and so we started a discussion of
whether it was a happy ending or not I
think we said the name happy ending so
many times in a row somebody finally
just said oh you should call the name of
the album happy endings and not really
yeah sounds good doesn't have to
happening so there was it was named you
know you change
[Music]
keep the star
I mean we all grew up you know playing
in rock bands and listening to all kinds
of music you know country music rock
music you know anything hip-hop so you
know it can't help but find its way into
your music Brad if you could be someone
else for one day who would it be and why
someone who sails around the world
because I'd always wanted to do that
which band member is most likely to get
into trouble with the law and why you
because you have Jeff what is the most
extravagant thing you've ever purchased
extravagant extravagance you know what
did I get
I bought that painting of the duck a
giant painting of a duck now but I do
Drive a 96 Corolla big cost more than my
car wit take a favorite song in the
album and explain why I like written
sane I really dig the minimalist
production and I think the powerful
lyric and that's just really cool songs
really like solid Jeff tell us something
about yourself that we'd never guessed
by looking at you I'm really good with
the yo-yo really really knows I would
have guessed that by looking at just
artists now I am so excited to
exclusively announce all the details
about Jerrod Niemann brand-new album are
you guys ready this ride features 13 new
songs including the wedding ballad God
made a woman
[Music]
for a man and a duet with lee Brice
called a little more love
[Music]
the album will be out on October 6 and
will be his first release on Curb
Records hey Sophie my new album this
ride has some of my favorite songs I've
ever recorded on it and I cannot wait to
share while we wait to hear more from
Jared I've got some fire song pics for
you guys this week
kicking it off with the Cadillac 3
demolition man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not already familiar with the
Nashville born-and-bred band's lead
singer Jared Johnson is a songwriter
behind hits like Keith Urban's raise
them up you going to fly and Tim McGraw
southern girl among honestly so many
other number-one their new album legacy
is out next week on big machine records
next up is jaren's longtime buddy Kip
Moore with the bull because to be
perfectly honest with you I'm just
really obsessed with his voice
[Music]
and thank you for the rack first of all
most of all thanks to the booths the
book beo last but certainly not least is
Brandon ray with ends of the earth which
was produced by Keith Urban and hitmaker
Ross copper man it is on its way to hit
data if you ask me
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
and with that it is time to say goodbye
until next week please keep in touch on
Instagram I am at so if we chalets the
ant if you like what you see here go
ahead and hit that like button and
subscribe to Entertainment Tonight for
more I'll see you all again next Friday
same time same place